how many men are living existences they
hate because they feel like i have to or
it pays slightly better you have to earn
more money yeah and they think the right
way to be a dad is to make sure that
every kid has a car when they're 16 you
can give them a full ride to college
they have brand name clothes so many men
you know they wake up one day and
they're 50 or they're 60 and they're
like there went so many years out of my
life and like i don't feel good about a
lot of what i've done like i've hated my
job i've been a wage slave you can
partner with your family and with your
spouse and say hey you know what let's
actually not upgrade the house even
though it would be great to have more
room so that dad can quit this job he
hates you know what let's downgrade the
house like we'll have three kids in a
bedroom throw some bunk beds in there
let's downgrade like let's live a more
free life so that dad can start that
business that he always dreamed about
doing and yes it might be a financial
disaster but let's be with dad as he
takes a shot on that so men are really
in need of that message of freedom as
well